it's it's so weird going on my feed and
I forget to change it for the for you
because I hate that it defaults to like
the recommended feed because that is
just a [__] cesspools it's like how
have you said YouTube when you open the
app it just loads are short
no okay let me show you what you
sometimes you open YouTube it just plays
a short is it because it might be
because the last thing wasn't sure right
uh so this time I didn't do it but like
let's say I was watching something I've
noticed that sometimes if I just close
it and then I come back to it later on
it'll it'll just [__] start playing a
short even I I wasn't watching ashore
what yeah I don't know
um maybe you just uh maybe I'm crazy
yeah sometimes it's like it's completely
reloading the app like I see it opening
it again like like from scratch and it
just loads a short I'm like what the
[__] [__] you how much shorts have you
been watching now you know you go down
the rabbit hole yeah have you noticed
the amount of like on Twitter the amount
of like every time you open it there's
just one person just being dunked on
with 100
000 retweet or query tweets or something
yeah I thought it was cute originally
and then I'm like oh this is like every
single day twice a day yeah it feels
like uh like I don't know how to I don't
know if this is correct word like not
like bullying culture but like that kind
of dunking on people is coming back in
again yeah yeah goes in and out online I
feel like it's slowly coming back in
again yeah being a hater is cool I mean
being hater has always been cool you
like even even before the internet I
just I just feel like maybe Twitter has
made it so that it's come right back to
the front line again and I feel like
okay here's his
I don't know I don't know if Twitter
still does this but it definitely did it
when uh uh when it updated for like you
know changing from the just the follower
feed to the for you page uh so this is
like the smallest like [__] designs
I've like come across right
so I wanted I want my Twitter feed to be
on my follower feed because the for you
page is just [__] awful but when I
when I log on when I first when this
would always have the updates huh I
always puts it on for you no no so so
originally it defaulted to the follower
but I would get notifications I'll get a
little little red dot saying you have
new notifications on your home page but
I couldn't get rid of that notification
by going to the for you page and uh
refreshing and going to the top of the
page so it basically forced me it forced
me with my little little [__] with
just just a little red dot I don't care
about those little red dots
wait you you don't you can go about your
life without going like getting rid of
every little notification
what do you mean look at all the dots I
have I have so many oh no no no no no no
no no I've got on iPhone is different
but I have 6083 no no oh guys 338 on
Discord I get pissed off about the
things that it thinks I like are Urgent
like why does my Fitbit send me
notifications to tell me I'm fat
she's [__] spamming [__] like wow
you've ran two days this week it's like
[__] off like I you know and like you
know BBC right I have the BBC app yeah
I'm like that's great that's hype I like
checking out news yeah what it defines
is urgent and sending me a [__]
notification before pisses me off yeah
it'll be like dog of the year actually
that's a good that's a good one yeah
that is urgent it's like it's like I
don't know it's something so dumb it
will be like I don't know man needs 15
burgers and hot dog eating contest new
record I don't want to check that out
and it's just like what like I I don't I
it's I don't know somebody turn that
[__] off
I think you can somehow but it's like
why why do you default do this I hate
this yeah I mean I cannot get on with my
day unless like every little
notification is gone otherwise oh dude I
mean there is there is just something
there and I it's a really bad like this
much always oh my God like this much oh
yeah it's a it's a really bad habit as
well because okay so one of the I was
actually late to the recording today
because we're meant to meet up at like
10 a.m and I came at like 11 p.m uh so
one of the reasons that happens
sometimes is because it's because of my
let's say uh OCD where I need to get rid
of every notification uh sometimes I
just like if I get a message sometimes I
don't even read the message sometimes I
just open it so I can get rid of it
get rid of the notification you are
actually the worst and then I'm just
like okay I'm going to sleep so so you
sent the message at like 9pm or
something yeah uh and I was like tired
after streaming because I finished like
half past midnight so I was going
straight to bed I was like I saw online
I had notifications I just remember I
think I remember like just tapping the
notification and then I'm like all right
done to bed and then I woke up
like quadruple this explains so much
about why you're so ass replying to
anything that's just getting a hold of
you there's so many moments where I've
like privately messaged gone about
something being like hey uh I need
information on this and it says [__]
red and I'm like
so you're gonna answer the riddle I
think people will get the assumption
that like gone is the most uh like
what's the word uh punctual or yeah get
a reply he's the worst out of all of us
no he's absolutely because I I you know
I have all those notifications are those
the ones that I deem as like in my head
I'm like I don't need to answer these
right now right yeah because if like if
you if I get a text I'll check my watch
that vibrates and like pops up and I'm
like that's not important I want to keep
doing what I'm doing yeah but if it's
important I mean like okay I gotta reply
to this all right um yeah so then I'll
reply at the end of the day off in a
week oh I I just replied everything on
the spot I'm just like I can't I can't
do that yeah because then like what if
it's not urgent and like because it
sounds like such an ass thing it's like
what if someone sometimes like the more
you reply the more Applause you get
right yeah sometimes I'm like I don't
want more replies because I want to do
the thing that I was doing yeah and so
if I if I reply they'll reply right away
and then I gotta reply again I'm stuck
in this cycle of endlessly trying to
like reply non-stop so I don't know
maybe maybe I'm just blessed because the
people who like I reply immediately back
to other people like gone who don't get
back to me for half a day so I'm like
all right good my side of the job is
done I'll just wait till he comes back
to me 12 hours later and I can just keep
doing what I'm doing yeah for me it's
it's like it's like half of that half I
check it I'm like okay let me just reply
after I finish typing the sentence and
then I finished typing the sentence and
then uh and then I just like okay I've
completely forgotten uh what I needed to
do uh so I just like uh and there's no
notification there so I'm just [__] uh
because here's is something if I if I I
knew if I don't see it it does doesn't
exist I need to reply right away oh I'm
going to forget and I know that so I
wish there was a function to be like
okay you've read it but can you keep the
notification there I don't know if there
is a function like that yeah emails do
that that's a lot that's why I can
manage my emails because emails I'm like
okay I open the email but I can still
have a notification that says has not
read some apps like you snooze like line
lets you snooze the notification oh okay
you should be like Ping me again about
this in two hours right right yeah
that's that's what I need in my life too
yeah I think you just hold down the
notification okay one thing that I don't
know if you've guessed ever done this
um you've ever mentally replied but you
didn't actually reply I do that all the
time well like in your head you read the
message and then you compose the
response in your head and then you think
you've sent it but then you used haven't
I know you've done this this is like
next level intrusive thoughts like like
you've thought of the response and then
you're like but then you mean you guys
distracted by something yeah and then
you're like oh [__] I forgot to send
that reply I never had the worst thing
is sometimes okay I I go like a step
further sometimes I literally type the
reply out I don't forget to send it no I
don't know
I get a message like two hours later
it's like so you can reply and I always
I always sound like I'm lying when I say
sorry I literally thought I'd reply to
you because you always sound like you're
just like that you sound like BS yeah
you always sound like BS but it's
genuinely true I do it all the [__]
time either eat like I just type I type
out the response I'm just like uh maybe
I need to like edit this I don't know if
this is the exact response I want I look
away and I just forget to press send and
then it was on Discord it would just be
gone it's typing for like three hours to
me it's like the mental equivalent of
looking for your phone when your phone's
in your hands you know you know you know
what I mean
you got your phone in your hand it's
like where where the [__] where's my
phone I've got to leave now I've got to
leave I was just I stopped a swimming
race one time I was about to start I was
like wait come find my goggles and
they're just on my head yeah I've done
that so many times
sunglasses as well
yeah I'm like I'm wearing them
probably why I'm into Gadget games so
much because every day I get it's just
like it's just a notification Fest like
ah let me do my deities and get rid of
all these red dots man let's clear it
out I when I played Hong Kong I was like
how many [__] mechanics are you gonna
introduce to me stop yeah every five
seconds is like all right now we have
this mechanic I'm like what is this
many people like you yeah you want to
log in every day and feel like they're
doing a lot of things but actually
you're doing nothing yeah I remember
when I first started playing genjin for
the first time like uh when I go back
into it
um like the first hour of that gameplay
was just me clearing notifications uh
and then and then I was just like okay
[__] now I actually have to play the
game but that was actually pretty fun
actually that was I felt a lot of uh
yeah that was a neurons activation it's
like cleaning your room it is right oh
it's all done yeah except it takes a lot
less effort so I enjoy it way more
because uh cleaning cleaning my room
actually takes effort you're doing that
while you're sitting in your dirty
officer right
yeah I don't know it's uh yeah my
brain's just wired weird uh yeah you
should only play gacha games yeah okay
okay here's the thing here's the thing
though
um okay have you checked your screen
time like how much how much time do you
spend on your phone uh how do I check uh
so you go to your settings right
so you go so you go to your settings and
you go to uh yeah digital well-being
parental control no why is it called
that it's called that because that makes
me sound like I'm I'm sick so this week
I've had a daily average of 7 hours 47
minutes
[Music]
it's
it's but it's down eight percent you can
tell me how many times I've opened my
phone yeah 160 on Tuesday what was what
went wrong holy [__]
[Music]
all right hold on let's see
okay so my digital well-being is
actually pretty damn good because I saw
some YouTube videos about this where
people had like 15 hours 20 hours what
screen time and I don't know how that's
even possible that means every waking
moment they are looking at your foot uh
looking at their phones they showed me
how many times I picked up my phone uh
daily average 91. yeah so actually like
90 YouTube yeah so actually like my like
compared to a lot of people uh I I asked
Sydney hers and she was like eight hours
nine hours and I'm like four hours uh
four hours or three hours 40. uh that
was that was that was that was a bad day
eight hours
um but yeah normally I'm in the rounds
between like between three hours and on
bad days eight hours but it never goes
beyond eight hours so I actually try to
minimize my screen time as much as
possible I'm not that bad
I don't know man I just saw one that's
in 10 hours that was um yeah like ten
hours four minutes yeah that's because I
was uh I was on a plane all right okay
okay I'll just watch YouTube but like
apparently I spent 33 minutes on
ubereats yesterday which how does that
even like has I think what must have
happened is like I have a I have a
mobile uh a wireless phone charger and a
lot of times I just like when I order
rubrics I just leave it open so I can
see where the like okay okay but like I
also uh I go in and out of phases where
I need like audio playing when I sleep
yeah but I just turned off my screen for
that that doesn't count towards yours oh
it doesn't no no no no yeah yeah I stop
my screen for that too so maybe I'm
coping uh but yeah but like yesterday
this makes no sense because yesterday I
was streaming literally from like dusk
till dawn right
um
and apparently I was still on my phone
for six hours how does that make any
sense I was I was literally I was
literally streaming the entire thing how
about my friend for six hours
YouTube mainly
while we're on YouTube while you were
streaming did you have did you have uh
your phone your YouTube on while you
were streaming actually I take a bath I
always watch YouTube when I take a bath
okay all right normally when I'm uh I
don't know if I wake up or if I'm
getting ready I just always like look at
I don't know if I can [__] dick we're
addicted to our phones
like a diamond rank screen time user I
actually don't I actually don't like I
actually don't think you're that high
because
um well screen time for for this device
yeah the other device
0.1 I don't count the computer wait wait
wait okay okay okay okay okay because
because it's work right because it's
work you know would an office worker
count the screen time for them on like
Excel no because I'm always in front of
a screen it's either my PC I'm either at
the gym and I'm running in front of that
[__] screen I'm I'm either taking a
bath yeah I'm pooping I'm always in
front of a screen but the thing is if
you're on your phone you're definitely
not working this is like the screen time
I spend on my phone is this is is the
time when I'm sometimes working
yeah
tell me tell me Joe what work are you
doing on your phone I'm doing like my
clothing stuff sell my stocks okay damp
it
but I mean I think it used to be a lot
more I think I actually I'm glad because
I've got my like I guess social media
screen time down I'm not scrolling so
much on Twitter and Instagram yeah I
wish they would the information is nice
but I wish there was like how can I look
at like how long I've what are the
trends that I've spent on certain apps
like have I spent more this month yeah
on like Twitter like why is that let's
have a look I know I know a lot of
people have those um those uh extensions
on Chrome that can like
block you from going on a website from
certain time periods
yeah I I I'll block Twitter because I
can't trust myself to not go on Twitter
while I'm working yeah which I've always
considered that but I'm like
did you get good just like just control
it just like mine never matter yeah like
I feel like I'm I don't know in my head
I'm like I want to be I don't know is it
weird that I'm like I want to be the one
who stops myself yeah no no I'm not yeah
you want to be in control I wanna yeah I
want to be telling like I wanna if if I
if the only way I can get control is
that I have to like physically block
myself I feel like there's an issue yeah
okay so I I actually saw this like this
is like a [__] Tick Tock or [__]
YouTube shorts kind of like device like
oh devices you need in your life and it
was literally a lock for your phone oh
yeah right have you seen that it was
like a safe my friend where where you
put your phone in the safe and you lock
it and you can't open it like you set
the timer and you cannot open that lock
yeah until the timer runs out and I feel
like if I did that I would obsess more
about how I could get this phone [__]
open this lock open than I would
actually trying to like not look at my
phone you know that that would be a
bigger distraction than actually having
my phone there in my yeah in my opinion
yeah I mean I understand understand that
some people they need to block things
you know like if you're addicted to like
gambling or something you have to like
you can submit the like the paper saying
don't let me in yeah yeah because I
understand stuff like that and yeah but
for like me personally uh for me like
self-control it's very important for me
to feel like I am limiting myself and
there's not some external Factor that's
limiting me yeah otherwise I don't
really feel like I've I've solved the
issue if I do have yeah an addiction to
any whatever it is
um and I I'd get so [__] pissed off
if my phone wasn't locked in a safe I
would so I'd be like I I actually have
to reply to something like I this is
stupid yeah I would find a way to like
go around that I'd be like okay now I
need to log into all my messaging
messaging apps on my computers now all
right and it would just like I don't
know that that to me would feel bad for
me because it would feel like I'm not in
control so I would be pissed off and I'd
be pissed off at myself for the fact
that I would need a device like that
um but you know I understand everyone's
mind yeah everyone has ever way uh for
me I just like feeling like I am in
control even if sometimes I'm definitely
not in [__] control everyone's got
addition to something everyone's got
that something that that they're like
damn maybe do this more than I should or
I'd I eat too much food or whatever it
is everyone has that advice or something
they're addicted to and it's it's up to
you to
keep control of that yeah
um hey hey hey hey hey now now now now I
I am I'm a gamer okay I I like the
gaming side I like the gaming side of it
guys
I'm I'm in it for I'm I'm in it for the
anime characters all right yeah